i wanted to talk a little bit more about
the strategy that used and share a
personal story that i have because i
dealt with
something similar to this um
yep i don't know it was maybe about 15
years ago right so i used to have these
three people that used to work with me
two of them were employed with me one of
them was working with one of the other
guys
and we were working on a project and i
would go over to the other guy's house
his wife would be there we'd have a
conversation we talked business food was
ordered you know she'd hang out for a
bit but leave
long story short they ended up
doing some
underhanded things which i can't talk
about because of the settlement
but similar to how andrew dealt with
this you know scenario one of the
strategies that i use when i had to go
legal on this and i did have to go legal
was i named the guy's wife
right she wasn't going to be on the
business contract but she was at the
house and she was tied into the
conversations from time to time
it was it was a strategy that my lawyer
talked to me about at length and i got
further counsel on it as well but it
ended up working and he ended up
settling simply because
the missus was involved and she didn't
want to get dragged into the lawsuit
have to go to court look bad on on
public record because of her profession
there's all this other stuff you know
too now but
you've like when it comes to conflict
okay guys and this is true for anything
you're going through the divorce machine
you're dealing with a business strategy
i don't think anything should be off the
table
okay you want to win you want to play to
win that's what playing to win looks
like you know
cobra tate is your is your pinnacle
example of this like this is the alpha
god sort of strategy that we're talking
about right now right like why would you
mess with a championship kickboxer
publicly and then back down that quickly
right clearly what you did worked
and you you know you nailed it because
we said earlier about how my boys will
go to war for me without thinking right
and no one's going to ask any wise as
soon as i said that man upset me nobody
was asking me what he did everyone was
just out to hurt him as much as possible
right and it's kind of the same because
if you don't have that network they also
won't take fire for you the same so you
just nailed it right his wife he settled
because his wife you instilled cowardice
you instilled fear inside of his own
camp because now his wife is in his ear
oh i don't need this just settle blah
blah that's another problem if you don't
have a serious circle of brothers if
they attack your brothers or the people
who are close to you they're going to
turn on you very very quickly and that's
another thing you need to consider like
if someone were to try and tie my
brother into something that involved me
my brother would like good because it
does involve me
like he'd be happy for it but most
people are not like that and and that's
where it's more and more important we we
talk about a lot of things in in this
kind of space and this side of twitter
but they all kind of tie back to the
same thing and they all tied back to
masculine networks and masculine support
systems in which you have mental honor
and to a degree real men of honor is
what we're talking about
yeah absolutely because men used to be
bound by something richard they're
either bound under a flag of a country
or bound by language or bound by the
need for survival we used to be bound
together and if you don't have brothers
that you're at least bound to buy
something you know if you're all just in
it purely for your own interest and you
meet you know three times a year and you
have a bit of wine whatever whatever
that's different you need to and this is
one of the things i i really do think
you know like my entire life has has
been
full of tribulation but uh i i i i
really do thank the
my upbringing and the fact that i grew
up in a very impoverished place because
the reason gangs exist are for survival
man this is why people join them this is
like i grew up with needing guys who i
knew would fight next to me and just
because i have money i nothing about my
mindset has changed
it's exactly the same and and i think a
lot of people try and pretend it's not
real like guys like colton or rhinestone
or whoever want to sit there and pretend
that twitter is to be all and end all
over the world it certainly isn't
twitter's a website there's real people
i'm a real person i'm sovereign i exist
one day you might see me
it's the guy next to you prepared to
take an ass kicking along with you
because if he's not why is he even your
friend you know like this goes beyond so
colton dobson was a fun little thought
experiment and it was you know it was
fun for me to mess with but it goes and
shows
it goes to show everything you're saying
about the people who are close to you
they're either on you firstly they need
to be on your side but secondly they're
your weakness look at what i did to
scott adams you see scott adams's wife
yeah that was brilliant
yeah that was great can i uh tell the
story
so
so andrew so andrew and scott adams and
if you know who's who who scott adams is
i mean he's on twitter he's very popular
he does coffee shows and blah blah blah
writes books and he's married to a
younger very attractive woman she's
she's what like 25 30.
something like that yeah and he's got to
be into his 50s maybe even 60. he's
significantly older than him
yeah i mean looking at that relationship
i knew something wasn't right
yeah i mean like right off the get go
i mean he's he's he's neither he's
neither alpha
or beta bucks but um yeah he was running
his mouth and all of a sudden you know
there's a a quick like 25 second screen
video on your phone of her
and you exchanging dms with hearts and
emojis and come on over sort of thing
just you know just like that you know
this is this is the man's wife right
because he was running his mouth so i
mean
it's it's beyond me why people try to
flick boogers at you i mean you've
clearly proven yourself but i guess it
gets lonely at the top and stuff like
this needs to continue to happen and
make sure that you maintain your uh
crown i suppose a lot of people aren't a
lot a lot of people aren't introspective
enough to truly understand how weak they
are
like i have genuinely done serious work
on myself and i've also consulted with
some of my friends which are extremely
high-level individuals we've done a lot
of work to see exactly how vulnerable we
are i know my vulnerabilities right i
know what they are i've analyzed myself
i know what you can find out about me
online
i know my weaknesses in regards to
females or friends or children or
offspring i've literally sat and
analyzed myself if you were to attack me
because i'm not scared listen there's
been points in my life where i had real
people trying to kill me and i'm talking
about real people i'm talking about
albanian gangsters with murder charges
so i'm not scared about ryan stone on
twitter and nobody i've been through it
for real so i've analyzed my life most
people haven't scott adams has never sat
there and thought what's my weakest
point well it's clearly my wife who
doesn't love me
that's a pretty obvious one to me i
looked at the dude and thought okay
that's how i piss him off that's gonna
take ten seconds boom boom
how many people do you think actually go
through a risk a risk assessment to see
how vulnerable they are like what their
weak points are i'd say it's really low
i don't think anybody does because just
like nearly everything else in the world
when people identify they have a problem
then they feel implored to act and
people are scared of action so they like
the ostrich
tactic oh it's fine and hide their heads
they don't want to sit there and go okay
what dirt on me really exists okay
where's my weak points okay who would
actually turn on me okay who would fold
under pressure okay which which which of
my business interests could be seriously
damaged by i mean even me and the way i
make money
i know you can't really damage me oh
you're gonna say the casino owner's a
bad guy are you oh yeah i'm sure no
one's gonna go to my casino who gives a
right like so i know my weaknesses
right and even even like a few a few
people have been clever and tried
they've messaged some of my girlfriends
and tried to get me caught cheating and
all this other crap that's all that
doesn't work because my girls know the
game so i have all myself myself's
pretty tied up but most people aren't
coltie never considered for a second he
didn't even know his weaknesses if you
don't even know where you're gonna get
hit it's gonna hurt twice as hard
hey you know again dude like i was
impressed with how
how much mouth was run i was like okay
well this is gonna happen then and then
how quickly it just
went quiet and disappeared and andrew
and i had a conversation and worked it
all out
that was that was that was rapid man
like that was impressive that that was
impressive
he looked out the window he himself
his mother looked out the window she
herself his whole family's in fear
and it has to come to an end
like what else is it gonna be
you